most of these people have lost
everything
floods have swept through the village of
tonsa in southwest pakistan destroying
their homes and livelihoods
roads that were clear just weeks ago
have turned to lakes leaving thousands
stranded
we've had more rain this year it's had a
severe impact on many areas along the
river belt the water has leveled off in
some parts but it already destroyed
homes crops and infrastructure
the aftermath is overwhelming more than
a million people have been affected by
flash floods and landslides and hundreds
have died across four provinces
climate change officials say is fueling
unpredictable weather patterns
entire communities across balochistan
province are homeless
when you look at the amount of rain
which has fallen
on balochistan province itself it's
450 times
what balochistan receives in a normal
year
so it destroys the home it destroys the
livestock you know livestock drowning it
destroys the infrastructure of course
bridge
road and it destroys the crop
authorities say nothing could have
prepared them for the extent of this
year's monsoon rains the army is helping
displaced communities but many survivors
say the response has been slow
we are not getting enough help from the
government we hear a lot of promises but
on the ground it's poor people who are
suffering we have no food no water and
we are living under the open skies at
the mercy of god
more heavy rains are expected in
southwest pakistan in the coming days
it's yet another concern for families
who've lost everything and are forced to
start over
katya lopesodoyan al jazeera